So it turns out these are all true.
All threads from a block can access the same variable in that block's shared memory.
That's what the shared memory is.
It's a chunk of memory that stores variables that are accessible from all threads in a given block,
and threads from 2 different blocks can access the same variable in global memory.
Well all threads from any blocks at any time
can access a variable or piece of data that's sitting in global memory, so this is also true.
Threads from different blocks have their own copy of local variables in local memory; yes, this is true.
So every thread has its own copy of whatever local variables--
private variables to that thread are sitting in local memory, so this is true.
And threads from the same block have their own copy of local variables in local memory.
Right, so just because they're from the same block doesn't mean that they share local variables.
They share shared memory--per block shared memory, but they don't share local memory.
So all 4 of these are true.